well i don't trust red wings you don't
trust me right away you trust red wig
you don't have to but i'm gonna go see
if he's right cause i have a feeling
they might be a part of the big three
androids aliens and wizards it's true
that is the big three no it's not every
time we fight we fight one of the three
so who are you fighting now gandalf
there are no wizards dr strange is a
sorcerer
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
welcome back to new rock stars marvel's
the falcon and the winter soldier
is the next mcu chapter following one
division with
falcon sam wilson and the winter soldier
bucky barnes teaming up on a mystery
mission
involving the return of zemo from civil
war and the whole legacy of captain
america
while promising to be a more grounded
straightforward action series compared
to the craziness of wandavision
we have also been promised a story
deeply rooted in marvel lore
and by the end of this episode i will
reveal what new crackpot fan theory
train i'm going to be chugging away
along
this is inside marvel new rockstar's
official after show for the falcon the
winter soldier i'm eric boss
and here with me for the next several
weeks to break down this series is
mt aka mastertainment hey man what's
going on everybody what's going on eric
i love
making nerd content with you so let's
get into it i just
it's gonna be good i feel it oh i feel
it too man this is this is so great
we've loved having you on uh as a guest
for new rock stars and past shows past
episodes of rogue theory
and big question and uh you just seem to
like get
the insane level of attention to detail
we put into this sometimes you know
going too far into a theory and getting
debunked on the other side
but taking it in stride and then getting
back up and keep going
it's because you do this all day it's
mostly because i'm insane um
yeah insanity yeah insanity is
definitely part of the
part of the madness that that sentence
was insane
i i understood what you said though
because we speak the same in science
that's right that's right oh yeah
so uh together uh empty and i are gonna
react to each episode as it comes out
and we're gonna do our best to answer
your biggest wtfs which for this show
we are gonna change it so that it will
now stand for what the falcon
subject to change that's pretty good
i'm a big fan i don't know if you saw
like
i grew up watching uh r-rated movies uh
edited for tv
on like tbs and tnt and they always swap
in different f words for the f word
so like the i think it was on die hard
two
where he says yippie kaye mr falcon oh
yeah
you'd be killed mr [ __ ] with totally
something that normal people say when
they're just epic oh
absolutely anger i'm just like oh i said
that you know what some car cutting me
off the other day i was like you beca
mother
mr falcon and he was like how did you
know my name was mr falcon
sorry and then uh pepper was on the
other side of you going do a barrel roll
i'm just like oh this is a dream i'm
into this it's like i'm oh i'm having a
minor
stroke this is uh all these people are
not real
so you are listening to our preview show
to catch you up on everything you need
to know going into the falcon the winter
soldier and empty and i are going to try
to explain how this show
is going to change the mcu forever it's
going to be a
it's going to be a big game changer oh
yeah a pretty big deal for
[ __ ] sure so we are also simulcasting
this live
on stereo stereo is the free podcasting
platform where you can interact with us
in real time sending us voice messages
that we will
air and respond to live be sure to
download the stereo app by going to
stereo dot com
new rockstars we're going to do a
special bonus q a uh
segment exclusive for our listeners on
stereo and that will air as a video on
the main channel on sunday
uh so if you missed it uh be sure to
join stereo and then you can get your
question read on the channel in a future
episode
so empty let's dive right into this
let's start with
what the falcon is this show
okay well i'm glad you asked that eric
well following avengers end game sam and
bucky are dealing
with the legacy of captain america's
shield obviously because we saw at the
end of end game
cap was like have this shield it's
pretty good you could put a
you could have a meal on it you could
throw it it's just it's fantastic
so old man cap gave it to sam who felt
like it didn't belong to him
but bucky gave an approving nod so yes a
very important nod because you know
there were fans in the audience who were
like
how does bucky feel about this right she
should go to bucky oh bucky nodded okay
i'm cool with it
bucky was the first best friend he was
here first he gets dim the shield
first okay yeah exactly uh bucky and sam
have always kind of had this love-hate
relationship
and really it has been defined by their
relationships with
steve rogers like bucky as you said he
was steve's friend
he was the old friend he was there when
he grew up he helped fend off bullies
uh and he was really defined by the good
old days the good old days of world war
ii a lot of horrible things happened but
you know we look back not a great time
hey rose tinted glasses nostalgia is
um but sam kind of came in there as
steve's
new friend at like the new school and
you know and that's all he cares about
now
always on his left amy um
then really he's defined by what we knew
of steve rogers after he
came out of the ice you know that kind
of modern rebirth he was the first
uh superhero or a friend who really
understood steve because until that
moment
until he found that friend jogging
around dc he didn't really have anyone
on the avengers who really got him
and what his struggle was and then in
civil war you know sam
and bucky had a lot of moments together
they bickered in the backseat of that
tiny vw bug
just that moment of them looking at
steve um making out with his
grand-niece maybe um yeah like
yeah incest
we're getting real uh you know game of
thrones here yeah a little bit
alternate alternate timeline all three
time like that makes everything okay
so really this whole series the falconer
soldier is meant to be a sequel to those
moments in in the cap films and in like
infinity war and in game
like it's growing out of those moments
yeah for sure for 100 sure like it's
it's
gonna be really cool to see like call
backs to those moments that of
those like falcon and and uh you know
winter soldiers i guess i should say sam
and bucky moments
um series and like they just i like
their chemistry even though they don't
like each other like this is weird like
um i love you but like i hate you type
the deal going on i'm like i like this
relationship let's see yeah how this
goes
but let's talk about bucky real quick
bucky james buchanan barnes i don't know
if you guys knew that's where bucky
comes from
buchanan yeah so what are the best or
presidents no one knows anything about
right
i'm going to tell you a single thing
about that anyway bucky
james buchanan barnes was steve's
lifelong best friend and fellow soldier
during world war ii they served in the
trenches together shot a bunch of nazis
it was fantastic
then um unfortunately not so fantastic
he got abducted by hydra
and um got turned into this
mind-controlled assassin the winter
soldier
by arnhem zola which was um you know
just a little side project for zola he
was like let's just make some super
soldiers why not
you don't have an arm don't worry about
it i'll make you a new arm still
i'll get you in there but uh steve's
loyalty to bucky was the primary wedge
in civil war as you guys remember and
especially when it was revealed
that bucky straight up murdered tony
stark's parents
in cold blood in that tragic tragic uh
motor vehicle accident
um that was a complete accident and
bucky didn't punch anybody in the face
repeatedly not at all
nobody it's was doing accident
um so bucky and steve and sam have
remained fugitives ever since invite and
direct violation to the sokovia courts
and then bucky yes
was recovering in wakanda of course um
as we saw in the beginning of
infinity war and um getting a new
vibranium arm which is
accustomed to wakanda you just come to
wakanda they give you some lemonade and
a new vibranium arm you need a vibrating
bar we'll get you a vibration right it's
just
joey get him a fiber anymore get this
amanda vibranium yeah exactly just
hospitality that's what you do yeah um
and so he was recovering in wakanda and
he was the first character that we saw
dust in infinity war ah yes that's right
which is a nice uh parallel
to uh sam wilson because sam wilson was
the first avenger voice we heard on the
other side of the blip coming
out of that so they kind of bookended it
for cap you know both uh
the guy who left him and the guy who
came back it was it's interesting
parallel isn't there
uh but let's talk about sam wilson this
guy uh mr on your left
was an air force pararescue airman he
was part of the x07 falcon team
he had a wingman named riley who uh
was gunned down unfortunately uh during
a mission
very sad uh and then wilson out of that
became a veteran counselor
and that's kind of how he met steve they
were they were jogging around dc
and uh they had this nice friendship and
he kind of was able to connect with
steve in that moment in a way that no
one else in this modern era was able to
connect with him
uh and then in this amazing winter
soldier movie uh steve
uh was helped by sam alongside black
widow when they were on the run
when uh when shield was revealed to be
corrupted by hydra
uh and then he was briefly in avengers
age of
ultron and that's kind of where he
became an official avenger by the end of
that movie
we caught up with him at the beginning
of civil war where he has this red wing
drone it was referenced to his
actual falcon friend in the comics
amazing i loved it
uh a bit cooler a bit something that
like he can brag about
uh when he's trying to pick up women in
a bar right right i have a falcon
you know some women might be like yes
please i mean
i don't know if there's a lot of bird
ladies out there but hey there's some
bird ladies
i mean there's some ladies out there
yeah they go to the bar to you
uh it's of course really where we got to
see uh sam and bucky collide and have
some great moments specifically in the
airport battle where the two of them
just got straight up embarrassed by
spider-man
it was great it was pretty great it's my
favorite they got some good hits on him
but spider-man yeah he's a child
who defeated them uh so by the end of
zamora cap freed sam from the raft
prison
and uh and then we catch up with him in
infinity war where they help
uh wanda envision of one division fame
uh in edinburgh and uh and then yeah
that movie ends with uh sam also dustin
uh but yeah as i said he was the first
avenger we heard return uh
that great radio message on your left uh
i love that the frequency that the
cap was on was the same frequency sam
was on when he was
you know fighting alongside him five
years ago it's like cap left to the
signal and he's like maybe just in case
they return right the signal
on frequency six and then there's some
truckers are like hey you on this one
it's like can you get off i'm waiting
for my friend sam
to undust thanks i appreciate it he's
like i'm just waiting for my uh my black
friend to disappear now can you just get
off this line please thank you
okay but
okay that was great breakdown let's talk
about zemo because zemo's going to be in
this too
and now zeno is of course returning from
captain america civil war
and after trying to turn the avengers
against each other um and he did a
pretty good job he did a very good job
a lot of punching um so but uh but also
he's uh trying to get revenge
for his family dying in the battle of
sokovia which was his main motivations
behind civil war
and his main motivations um behind
talking the winter soldier because he
just does not like the avengers at all
doesn't mean this should exist no hero
should exist
so he's just you know i'm gonna put on
my purple mask and
you know mess things up um yeah he's
because he's good at it um and then
of course um when he framed bucky for
several war crimes that's uh that was a
very good job on
z most part and uh he killed t'chaka
which was very sad uh black panther's
father if you don't remember
and uh it was a very touching moment and
i was just like man
i gotta go call my dad i gotta call my
dad right now because
yeah you never know you never know uh
um trooper might frame a winter soldier
too exactly
call your dad right now everybody
because zemo might be coming for him
that's terrible i'm so sorry that's not
true your dad's fine
um and now of course he's wearing
his a signature purple mask from the
comics which i was very much missing
in a captain america uh civil war so we
got it happy we're getting there we got
the promats and
i don't know how marvel does this they
find a way to make it look cool it looks
so practical how do they do that it's
just the ridges
i think it's the ridges in it right it
looks very
like realistic and less stupid because
in the comics you're just like why is he
wearing this
on his face looks so silly oh it's just
they don't have enough purple villains
yeah it's true we need more purple
villains bring on the purple
exclusively purple honestly
uh now another element to the falcon
winter soldiers we got this new cap
figure that actually trailers for this
series have only shown
little bits and pieces of and that is us
agent john walker it's gonna be played
by
wyatt russell now in the comics this
character starts as the name uh super
patriot he's kind of like a wrestler a
self-made vigilante
whose whole goal is to try to make
himself famous for being such a hero
that he has to be the successor to
captain america um
now here he seems to they seem to be
following a similar arc he's kind of a
government pick successor
for the captain america title a sort of
pr stunt man
actually the way the government used
steve rogers as a poster boy back in the
40s
so really just like a cap and name only
you would say uh and
there have been posters and trailers
actually uh showing up proclaiming kappa
is back
uh that have been tied this is the the
u.s agent version of cap
of john walker the u.s agent yeah and
then uh the government
at the end of the day for whatever
reason does not want sam
to be the next cap and this series is
gonna go into the reasons why that might
be the case come on uncle sam
let another sam get a chance all right
come on
let nephew sam have a turn at the wheel
right
jesus christ the government
i'm just kidding government's fine um
but yeah i'm very much
i'm very interested to see what uh how
u.s agent is going to
play into falcon military soldier
because um he just seems like a really
just i don't know what they're gonna do
with them and like there is like people
like are is sam even gonna get the
shield like there's
like been talk about like if if uh sam
wilson is even going to uh become
captain america which
i'm sure he will be because kevin feige
has been very clear he's he's gonna be
cap
um it would be very weird if he wasn't
he's either gonna be at least to carry
on the spiritual legacy
of what cap means to people sam seems to
be the embodiment of that or hopefully
it will be by the end of this
oh yeah for sure um but yeah but there's
also
a new group called the flag smashers led
by aaron kellyman's character
in the in the new falcon and we're
soldier show and they're based on the
cat villains
flash smasher in the comics and his goal
was to tear down
all national flags and iconography and
just just to like unite the world
under one common mindset in general yeah
these are the ones in the trailer that
just have the red hand print on the face
a lot of people are like oh that's going
to be the hand
but probably not right oh yeah that's
doesn't really match the whole hand yeah
they're not ninja they're not secret
ancient ninjas
you wouldn't see them if they were the
hand that's the thing the hands that
should have been in the mcu from the
beginning they're just so good
that they have not left the shadow or
they've been right behind the cameraman
if you're if you can see the hand you're
probably on the ground in a pool of your
own blood die
from the hand that's how you know so
yeah you're not going to see the hand
that's how you know it's the and
that's how you know it's the hand why am
i doing enchanted what has happened to
me
it's a it's because of all that one
division you got one
everybody needs a theme song oh did the
lopez's do enchanted i wouldn't surprise
me maybe i'm just thinking
they had worked with the dina menzel and
let it go and she was in enchanted
it's it's the multiverse is collapsing
in my brain
is what is happening exactly
the uh but yeah you know this whole idea
of like tearing down the flags
when you say that empty it kind of
sounds like oh this kind of sounds like
a noble quest
for a group of freedom fighters to go
for of like let's just like
tear down warring nations and forget
about these political divides
and just see if there's things that we
have in common what's wrong with that
i know right it sounds noble but uh it
seems like they're going about this
through very radical meaning right
right they're taking it to an extreme
that at least can't get on board with
that train
no i mean like i'm all about for you
know you know michael jackson song
we are the world
we are the children yeah i'm all for
that but with less uh you know violence
and explosions i mean
it's good to watch on disney plus from a
distance but if i was
living in a world with uh flag smashers
blowing [ __ ] up i'd be like i don't want
i don't want to go to the supermarket
show up yeah smash my groceries
just they just smash things they take uh
gallons of milk and smash it plug
smashers
like are you really about the cause of
tearing down uh political divisions
yeah yeah that's that's that's part of
it but also
your fashion you know what i mean if
their high school
history teacher is like you have to give
a reason behind your smashing flag
smashers
okay what about politics sounds good
politics is always a dicey subject so
just go with that there will always be
politics
um so what i'm one of the things i'm
most excited about this series mt is how
it's going to be expanding the map of
the mcu uh
you mentioned how you know zemo's from
sokovia in the trailer there's a shot of
him
standing in front of the sokovian
memorial with a big crater lake
you know behind him that looks like it
could be part of the runoff of when that
city
smashed back into the terrain right uh
so i love that like both falco winter
soldier and wand division are kind of
revisiting sokovia
there's more to like explore there and i
hope this series does that
um but also this new fictional setting
of madrapore
so magipore is a criminal haven for the
marvel comics
it's its own island nation that's
located near singapore and
it is known for having connections to
wolverine and the hand as we mentioned
those ninjas that you'll never see until
they kill you uh but
a lot of people are saying this actually
might be a small setup for shang chi
which is uh going to be revolving around
the mandarin in the 10 rings
who you know might be hosting this
fighting tournament rumor has it on an
island
in the nearby south china sea so the
mandarin would be someone who would hang
out in madrid
oh for sure we wouldn't be surprised to
see him there but also
sharon carter the the girl herself uh
she is coming back along
with batroc the leaper i loved the fight
between
captains up here and bad truck the
leaper yeah at the beginning of winter
soldier it was just oh man
that boy could leap he was that's it
wasn't false advertising
and he is he this guy george st pierre
is so excited
for the falcon winter soldier i think he
said in interviews like oh whatever you
think about the one division uh the
first one is soldier
is going to uh surpass it you know
oh how is the fact of the worst soldier
gonna be crazier with theories
than one division but it got me excited
i'm like maybe he's right
maybe i haven't learned my lesson to
stop listening to cast members of these
shows so they're trying to hype us
up seriously they love to hype up their
show it's like it's going to be the
greatest show we're going to have the
luke skywalker camera luke skyget walker
is going to show up himself
so we shall wait and see if it's as
crazy as one division but i hope so
because wanda vision
was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
timeline wise this show takes place
after end game correct
yes it will be after end game um from
what
we understand i mean it makes sense he
has to shield down a cap doesn't
shield anymore out of the picture yeah
um and
we just don't know when actor rang is
end game exactly that this is going to
take place but
set photos do show construction signs
reading rebuilding the world after the
blip
so it could take place weeks after end
game like one division was or
a few months yeah yeah definitely
definitely uh we also want to shout out
some other cast members who might
be part of the cast uh uh carl lumley
uh was rumored to be in this miki
ishikawa
and clay bennett showed up in one of uh
i think it was sebastian stan's
instagram photos and based off his
costume he had this star on his chest
some people think he could be lamar
hoskins who's battle star
who's a companion early companion of
john walker in the comics
um so we're not really sure but uh with
uh as with one division it's very
important for us to acknowledge who the
creators behind the scenes
are because you know if we had been
following jack schaefer and matt shakman
more with wanavision those are the
voices we need to be listening to
because they're the people who
understand how this is all coming
together they've seen the full big
picture they were there from the
beginning with the pitch
uh so following their interviews this
week has been figuring out
what the hell was going on in one
division or why they asked evan peters
um so in this case with the falcon
winter soldier obviously kevin feige is
kind of the
the grand master overseeing everything
yeah you know he's gone
he has got himself very hands-on with us
yeah yeah
um but the head writer is uh this writer
named malcolm spellman who is an amazing
writer he's one of the reasons i'm most
excited for the show he worked on empire
uh and the director is kari skoglund who
is a long time tv writer
she's worked on like everything just
like matt shachman had kind of worked on
everything you could look at her credit
she's like worked on
punisher she worked on house of cards
she's worked on the walking dead uh a
ton of stuff
um but malcolm spellman if you ever have
a chance to read this one of this guy's
interviews or listen to one of his
podcasts this guy
is awesome he uh he has confirmed that
this series is going to address
race in the legacy of captain america
specifically how a black man faces
taking on that title
and uh he is like he would not be part
of the show
that's like his whole vision is to kind
of like no we need to talk about this
stuff
it's important uh and he's got such a
voice for it he is very much
kind of like spike lee in that regard
he's like the whole point of media is to
try to force to challenge people's
notions
of what right and wrong are and to
challenge authority
and i'm here for it i'm so excited i'm
all about that i'm
just gonna be like i really hope that
they can nail that commentary
and um just just explore what it's like
to be
sam um taking over this iconic role from
from steve rogers and
um there's gonna be a lot of backlash
and um so it's just it's going to be
interesting to see how uh
they tackle that in the mcu yeah and one
of the uh references that spelman
brought up was the hbo watchman
and how you know general tv viewers of
superhero content are kind of ready for
those kind of conversations and one of
the things
watchmen did is it challenged that
notion of oh you thought hooded justice
was a white guy but actually the real
history of it
was he was a black guy and they were
able to go back to that
earlier preceding history and that seems
like something they might be doing about
winter soldier this isn't confirmed this
is really just a theory but a lot of
people are thinking if carl lumbley is
part of the show
that they might be looking into the
history of the character of isaiah
washington in the marvel comics who is
kind of considered
the black cap who was a test subject
from steve rogers era but his whole
history
of being an alternate captain america
was erased because it didn't fit the
narrative of steve rogers captain
america
right and i think it could be such a
great opportunity for malcolm spellman
in the mcu
to bring in that whole uh hidden history
of the character of the legacy and
giving power to sam being the rightful
heir to
this mantle yeah i'm all about that like
it's gonna be oh man
it's gonna be so good it's gonna be so
good it's gonna be good
everything that you just said it just
got me more hype i'm just like yes
let's tackle these things let's let's do
it let's do because like with
i love the direction kevin feige is
pushing the mcu because he's not
just making your cliche superhero movies
and the thing is though he could just do
that but he's
good yeah and he's making these movies
with these with these messages and with
these perspectives that are just so
amazing and unique and he's using disney
plus in the best way to do it so
yeah let's get it let's do it and that's
the thing like with all these shows
they're defying the genre you know
uh one division we just thought would be
kind of a run-of-the-mill
with some weird goofy homages like we
would have a scene that took place in
the bewitched reality but no they spent
three episodes
challenging us being like we don't know
what the show is uh
and and then delved into horror in ways
that i never thought they would do
witchcraft like you know so i could see
absolutely this is a great opportunity
for them to uh bend genre in another way
and bring in some themes they
they've rarely addressed you know yeah
so i think it's a great opportunity so
just to give you guys some
strict details on what this would be
it's gonna be six episodes uh
40 to 50 minutes each they're gonna be
airing weekly we're not sure if there's
gonna be like two episodes in the first
week it sounds like it's just gonna be
one one one one one one one
and then uh each episode i love this has
a budget of 25 million dollars so
wow that means a movie level budget uh
like game of thrones
later seasons level production value you
can expect
um massive action set pieces they're
gonna they're really trying to evoke
that buddy action
uh genre like uh lead the weapon bad
boys
midnight run uh based off trailers
you've probably seen this stuff like um
there's a fast and furious type scene
atop speeding trucks in europe yeah yeah
uh we got point break style aerial
fights with wingsuit gliders and
sam spinning through canyons it looks
nice
yeah it definitely looks like a 25
million dollar per episode budget
yeah absolutely man this is literally
what we need after not being able to see
a marvel movie in theaters
yeah just give us the marvel studios
level content at home
it's amazing uh and then there is like
some bar fights i'm not sure where this
is i love a good bar
fight but this looks like it's in the
bronze monkey saloon now i gotta you
know mia culpa i was wrong in the
trailer breakdown i thought they were
scroll heads
i initially thought they were ape heads
but they were
uh you know they actually were the
bronze monkey salutes a place in the
comics
that is related to captain america
comics so hopefully that is a place
they'll go
so of all this empty what are you most
excited about as we look
down the barrel of this show i am really
excited about just diving more into zemo
because zemo was a fantastic villain
in civil war one of the best villains in
all of the mcu
and uh just diving into just learning
about his family his
his family life we got to see more of
wanda's family and one division with
that flashback which was a very very
tragic so marvel knows how to fill the
tragic uh
you know flashback and all that stuff so
we might actually
end up feeling for zemo more um which is
i'm really excited about because i like
feeling for a villain i like being
conflicted like that's
just like cut my emotions kevin just
please just do it please
so yeah i'm i'm mostly excited for zebra
how about you man what are you doing
same thing uh with zemo but also with
sam and bucky
all three characters i think i've gotten
like uh
pieces of but not the complete picture
in the same way that like
you know uh wanda envisioned win like
feige announced all these series they
all i mean
loki i we've gotten a lot of loki i
always want more of him though
but like those two titles one division
in pocket winner soldier i'm like
hmm they aren't real they're kind of
like the b stars
of mcu they've had great moments but we
don't really get to know who they are
i'm saying this about the winter soldier
he has been a title character in the
movie i get it
i sound like an idiot right now but uh
but even then i still haven't gotten the
complete picture so the way one division
went to wanda's history and
really gave us a sense of what is going
on inside her mind
vision brought so much humanity to the
character i want uh sam wilson i want
more
humanity to his character i feel like
that his whole story of what happened to
riley
just kind of came and went in the falcon
when or what's it called though
captain america winter soldier uh i want
more of that like i want to see more of
what he's had to live with you know oh
yeah we're definitely gonna get a riley
flashback and it's gonna be
so sad yeah i think so um
yeah so i'm all about it i'm very much
looking forward to seeing sam's family
just seeing what his whole family life
is like yeah
yeah the wilson family their their
seafood folks they uh they got a seafood
stand
and man i can't wait to see benji with
babish recreate some of those recipes
so uh this is new rockstars we're gonna
delve into the theories
of this show and what we can look
forward to there uh first we wanna give
you some news from our merch partners at
epic hero shop
that vision shirt it's going dark on
sunday night
at the end of the weekend sunday night
at midnight west coast time
so this is your last chance to grab that
latest obsession shirt the robot variant
an unusual couple so grab yourself one
before it is gone
however we do have a new one division
celebration shirt to remind us that
after everything it was
agatha all along oh also if you you
might have guessed this our next shirt
in the latest obsession line is going to
be for the falcon winter soldier
uh we are still working on it but the
mystery design is going to be revealed
very soon
but we won't do that until the vision
shirt goes dark
so it's coming it's coming but also a
little reminder that epic hero labs
still has nine ps5s to give away
all you gotta do go to epicheroshop.com
giveaway click on the link in the
description to enter and you will see
all the details so if you are over 18
and in the united states just enter to
win a free ps5
very very exciting all right mt what is
our next what the falcon what the what
the f
is this new shield and where did old cap
even get it from
yeah so we have to acknowledge a lot of
the trailer footage has focused on this
shield right close-ups of the shield
it's all about that shield
uh the russos say that uh old cap and
avengers end game
you know this guy just showed up at the
end and we're like oh that's sweet he's
an old man now he lived a life
well where did he live that life uh the
russos the directors of endgame say that
he lived
his life in an alternate branch history
an alternate timeline in the multiverse
that somehow he got back to the prime
one the screenwriters were like oh no he
just lived within this history and he
was here the whole time in the
background not helping prevent the jfk
assassination prevent 911 or help them
out during the battle
of new york or any of these things he's
playing bingo i mean
it's a lot of bingo to do as as we saw
with wandavision sometimes the writers
despite these being some of the best
screenwriters working right now
do not think out everything fully yeah
it's hard it's
it's not easy to think through every
plot hole that you're gonna run into
um but i think we can assume if cap was
from an alternate history that's far
more interesting because it brings up
the question of where did he get the
shield
you know because it clearly is a
different design it has new notches new
indentations in it
the old shield during the battle the
whole shield that cap had pretty much
the full time the mcu
was splintered broken in half shattered
and then in a game
yeah it's gone so this is a new one uh
and there's a whole new story behind it
i've speculated in videos that this if
it did come from an alternate timeline
might be made of a different substance
than vibranium
specifically what it was originally in
the marvel comics
proto-adamantium uh which is kind of
like the special material it's like a
vibranium ally that's been enhanced
uh ally alloy but it's you know it's
allegiant to vibranium
yeah um but yeah yeah it's it's meant to
be stronger
more durable and it's uh it was weapon
x's attempt to recreate that material
that got them to the adamantium that
they put in
wolverine's skeleton so it's kind of
linked in that way
wolverine and cap their histories uh so
that's why i think there's a chance
wolverine might show up in some way or
he might get alluded to
in some way maybe it's too soon for that
though so i'm not that's not the train
i'm getting on mt
i'm not getting on the train
no i that would be really cool if there
was like illusions towards just
adamantium
and um and uh the whole weapon x project
um just like hey it's common
it's not here yet but you know they're
around um i would love that so much
it's like just finding out where this
new shield came from if like
if like at what point during caps like
stay in that
alternate timeline um if you if he met
up with like an alternate universe
t'challa and it's like hey man
yeah could you just repair this for me
because uh i know you don't know me but
i mean i guess they would know each
other just be a different version
i mean multiverse travel man it's just
it's it's weird and you gotta think like
cap went to that alternate timeline
around the late 40s so he would have
been hanging out with t'chaka
and so that's one way if you want to try
to find a way to show
cap's alternate history with wakanda you
don't have chadwick boseman sadly
anymore
but you could just have younger actors
playing t'chaka and that's
he has a relationship with him in this
alternate timeline you know that's very
very true that's very true t'chaka would
uh definitely help him out there
i'm sure that there's uh this is
probably a new shield um fixed up from a
different reality
yeah and you know we it has been
confirmed that chris evans is gonna
return to the mcu for
or he's in it's not confirmed i believe
he it's confirmed that he's in talks
i don't think the ink has been signed
yet but uh
but the there are two new mcu movies
that he is in talks to
appear in and if it's chris evans he's
not going to be old manchester united
it's gonna be young chris evans and the
only way that makes sense is if he is in
this alternate history
so what is that history is it with him
exploring wakanda helping them with
stuff
is he going out to free bucky from the
clutches of hydra i would hope so
um i would just hope this could be one
way that wolverine gets introduced like
because
you know their histories are so
intertwined i'm not saying it's gonna
happen
in the falcon winter soldier but yeah
you know if it's just implied
yeah if they give us answers to where
old cap came from you know
yeah that we can do the rest marvel yeah
but now i i really hope that uh chris
evans doesn't make a cameo in the show
because
oh it'd be it just it just feels right
it feels like he should at least be like
hey guys what you guys doing shenanigans
i mean you know
it's just i don't know i just feel like
just having that at least that flashback
or
or um you know just a detail of like all
right this is where i got the shield
right here's the answers but marvel
doesn't like giving us answers
we have to just slowly wait for them
drip by drip
now would you want uh young chris evans
because young chris evans would be from
an alternate thing or it would be shown
in flashback
uh if if it stays in the present day it
would
have to be old chris evans and that old
makeup again which
i feel like chris evans would be willing
to do he's a trooper he's a nice guy
oh yeah he's a trooper i i mean i
personally would like to see old chris
evans uh old man cap
yeah um just so you know because like
the trailers are sort of alluding to
you know a cap unfortunate passing
um so it would be really nice and really
touching just to
see him go um so you think we might open
because yeah as you said we saw sam
in kind of that those dark dark suit you
know
you know uh wistfully looking at uh
cap smithsonian uh exhibit
so do we think we could open with a
funeral for steve rogers the old man
steve rogers
yeah i definitely think that that's a
high possibility um
and but like i just really since captain
america is one of my favorite mcu heroes
i think would just be really touching to
have like a
death bed type scene with chris evans
and um
and cap and bucky and it would just be
really nice because uh
he he busted his ass trying to save the
world uh throughout his entire life so
we deserve that kevin please kevin kevin
kevin please all right our our next uh
what the falcon what the falcon is
zemo's plan like how
how did he get free from custody because
he's out about now how did he get out
i mean that's a good question i mean it
could easily be the blip i mean like
okay
yeah if he disappeared during the blip
and he came back and like in the middle
of like i don't know when he's like hey
i'm prison anymore it's pretty good i
will have the baconator
like sir you look really mad he's like
i'm still thinking about my family
yeah i'm just i'm really upset about my
family and and the fact that i got
snapped but mostly my family
um and yeah so like maybe he came back
from the blip
maybe he uh orchestrated a prison break
which would be a lot cooler
yeah zemo would be able to do that
um or um he could be released as part of
a thunderbolts-esque
initiative yeah so that's a big theory
because uh
zemo's whole backstory in the comics at
some point he becomes kind of citizen v
where you know he's like uh trying to
create his new version of the avengers
and it's called the thunderbolts
uh and then there's a lot of people who
are tied tied in with it i believe
goliath might be they all kind of take
on different names yeah but then they
turn on zemo because they hate them uh
and they're like
we're actually gonna be straight up good
guys he's like i am so upset
it's like the plan i give him a german
accent where he's he has closer to a
russian exit in the movie
daniel bruhl yeah uh so yeah yeah we'll
see if that ends up happening uh that's
been kind of the
speculated theory um i'm not sure about
that that might be uh
they might lay the seeds for it i don't
think we'll see it in the show we're
talking six episodes spoke six episodes
whose story is it it's we gotta learn
our lessons from one division if you
want a story
it is not thaddeus thunderbolts raw
story or whatever
you think this is imagine if they just
switch it up it's like this is actually
thunderbolt's boss's job
yeah if we're just watching an old man
just do old man things just like i'm
i'm taking my fiber pills now
time to go to work and yell at good guys
for some reason because i'm just always
just a downer i'm just curious to see
what uh
zemo's role he's such a wild card right
now and you know there are some shots in
the trailer where it looks like he's
teaming up maybe with sam and bucky or
at least he's kind of
giving them a tour of madrid leading
them somewhere
uh so why aren't they immediately trying
to beat him up and tackle him and
restrain him
right now like what has he been able to
offer them
and that's why i think there might be
something thunderbolts inspired like
maybe he's like look your government has
abandoned you
you can't go home right now because of
the sokovia accords
so let me give you an opportunity to
make a new name for yourself
i mean maybe i mean but or this could
also just be a trap
because zemo is a it's a trap
don't trust him yeah i agree yeah and uh
he could just be like hey come over here
let me show you something real
cool it's just like ah it's a you're in
a pit now you fell into my trap
um so who knows uh that's a very good
point and
i i just don't trust zemo because he's
just so smart
yeah i never trust him he is a very
smart guy uh
yeah and at the end of the day i i think
it'd be really hard for bucky to ever
trust zemo after
the way he did him dirty in civil war i
mean the guy made his life a living hell
he created
you know he he led to bucky getting his
arm ripped off
and you know having to go back to
siberia and fight each other you know
and no one likes there's another um
thing that is very interesting cause
like
because zemo's from sokovia there is a
chance that we
could have a one division tie-in um
with um this show because obviously
wanda is from sokovia
zemo's from zakovia so they're both you
know maybe they were neighbors maybe
right let's just see empty would it be
awesome if we found out that whole
battle that was happening in the streets
the
the night of the max moths death the
parents death that like that
stark bomb that went that air raid that
happened that zemo might have been on
the streets in that moment you know that
he
he looks up at the window and sees arena
that's
not closing the blinds like if they can
get
that way bro that's such a good idea
that's such a good idea oh my god
oh my god i'm all about that i mean all
he has to say is like when i was 14 i
fought in the sword i don't know how old
uh uh zemo is supposed to be i think
he's uh he's got 10 years at least on
the max mops right he's supposed to be
he's
in the 40s somewhere yeah yeah something
around there
so oh man that'd be such a good really
cool perspective it's like
hey what are you doing up there watching
movies ah this is zemo's story now
yeah oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
i'm all about that now you got me
excited because i just oh man
yes that's so good now in the in the uh
teaser scene that
empty and i reacted to it at the top of
this there's this great moment where sam
sorts the supers of the world into the
big three androids aliens and wizards
and i'm curious so what the falcon is
the new threat that he's trying to sort
you know who is he saying this this is
one of those three
um but let's try to just like quickly
sort who he's talking about so for
androids he would have been talking
about
ultron vision but maybe also bucky
because in all the trailers he's like
hey you got the mechanical mind
up there where's bucky the only part of
him that's mechanical is his
arm but like he has been programmed so
it's kind of mean to bucky that he keeps
saying he's got a robot brain
sam's a little bit of a joke but that's
why we love him uh
and i love that he calls people aliens
because you know he's talking about like
thor
and loki and valkyrie people who came
from asgard which to him he's like hey
they ain't from here they're aliens
but also the guardians of the galaxy
thanos the scrolls the cree
maybe even captain marvel because she's
been gone forever she comes back she's
got a superpower she's an alien
i mean yeah i mean falcons show like
imagine coming back from the blip and
being surrounded by an army of just
aliens me like what is going on what are
we about to do what is this like oh
we're about to go fight thanos he's like
oh
shoot aliens galore just aliens
uh and then wizards were getting a
bigger picture because this whole debate
is about doctor strange whether or not
he's a wizard based off whether he has a
hat
or not uh yeah we got uh dr strange
wanda maximoff uh wong agatha
presumably this takes place after
because it was so recent in one of
it's only three weeks so for all this
stuff to be taking place
i do have this theory that it could be
the multiverse's big week
and that's what we're seeing all these
series are taking place in those that
three week period or that month
period after after avengers end game
ends
but i'm thinking it's like a couple
months but it seems like they're still
in that period of like
the blip just happened so and so hasn't
blown all the leaves off their driveway
yet
uh everything's still kind of overgrown
the groundskeepers are still figuring
out
what their shift is so uh we'll see but
uh of these different uh groups mt who
do you think
sam and bucky are talking about who are
they going off to face right now in that
moment
because they know who zemo is they know
zemo isn't one of those three
must be some other group why did they
consider the flag smashers one of those
three if they are just like oh
you know a militant group it's it's it's
suggesting that they have some kind of
advanced powers that they could
yeah do really good work or something i
would guess
androids um if anything they were
experimenting with um
like ai and all that stuff in one
division and so like
who knows like who knows if uh androids
or robot technology has advanced um
super far at this point in 2023 i
believe
in the mcu yeah um so and that could be
why yeah uh that could be why you know
sam
keeps making fun of uh falcon or
bucky's robot braid he's like you're a
robot you should get other robots he's
like these are your people
of course it's just my arm dude um i'm
wondering if like in this moment mt they
might be headed off to match report and
you know maybe the hand is involved in
this so they're like who are these crazy
ninjas
that's i'm not saying the flag smashers
are the hand but it could be that
or it could be like there are we're
starting to see elements of
supernatural powered people on earth
that they don't have
an answer for and that we could starting
to be starting to see
mutants just like hints at hey this
person had powers they weren't on our
list before the blip
now they are i don't know who this is
and maybe we're starting to see signs
that
people have these superpowers that you
know it doesn't make sense for them to
have it
maybe we still don't have answers about
monica rambo she had powers before she
went through those hex walls
so maybe the mc saying she's just one
example of someone just around the world
who has these like weird powers now like
they're
their physiology is weird and maybe the
mutant gene is the answer to that yeah
possibly the snap like activated
something in the
in like some cosmic part of their
biology that the celestials from the
past probably put in and
it's just like all right this tragic
thing happened to humanity yeah let's
just activate this now
just uh this other protection let's get
my consolation prize some of them will
now have powers
but it'll be traumatic for them but yes
but like you know that they could just
explain it away as just like all right
the earth is trying to protect itself
like they do in the comics i believe in
the
uh earth x series um and like it's just
like the earth is trying to protect
itself so
let's just put mutants now and like you
know people are now superpowered and
like
you know just in case another thanos or
something comes around yeah um so yeah
yeah it could be like a natural step of
evolution right is there trying to make
humanity
and terrans better fit for survival in a
broader universe
is now their mutant genes get activated
because they need them
we need to make a certain percentage of
the population supernatural warriors
all right our fifth and final what the
falcon let's
a steer right in the theory corner mt uh
what insane marvel fan reveal can we
look forward to in this series
and let's go rogue gear let's go insane
okay i mean
i think that we could actually get a
zola cameo
i was about to say the same thing
if you follow if anybody follows me on
twitter i've been obsessed with the zola
thing
i honestly thought zola was behind
everything in wild division
oh nice i was so convinced because like
one division takes place in new jersey
yeah it's right there it's right there
it's right in the same
store is this camp and stuff where is
zola was uh
was based in so i was like oh man it's
zola but this is a more appropriate show
for zola to actually
make a reappearance in and as we saw if
you i don't know if you guys remember in
winter soldier
um where uh zola was uh all you know
computerized up
there was a usb drive oh
so even though zola like his whole
computer thing was destroyed there is a
chance that zola could still be alive
yeah because he could just be stored on
on that usb stick that cap took out
or just in another hydra usb or whatever
just backed up somewhere else because
technology now and and they keep
bringing him back i mean
they showed him on the background the
vfx artist put him in the background
of that lab and end game uh yeah he's
been there three times see it's kind of
like
the recurring ghost in the machine of
the mcu and they love him they love
bringing them back in little forms and
even the endgame screenwriters were like
we would love to bring back zola uh in a
way and uh they
actually had an idea to merge him with
with modoc
i kind of want modoc to be a separate
thing personally because yeah modok's
insane and crazy and
hilarious um but like
yeah uh to bring back arnhem zola in the
mcu
uh i think it's not too much to ask it's
not too crazy just to hear his voice
or if it's not uh toby jones some other
actor who's like derived from zola like
the next
os reboot of uh of zola
so high sierra can we say it can we say
it
empty is the train we're on for the show
the zola train
i think we're on it now i think we're on
the zoma train
let's do it let's go for it why not or
not the zola train mtr and i are on one
of those hand carts where we're just
you
they love them they want to bring it
back and they had those plans for that
zola
robot body that he is in the comics that
was among his blueprints back in the
first adventure movie
oh my god i want to see that i want to
see it i don't think we'll see it
it would be wild if we did i hope we do
um i really hope we do but they're
they're we're going to be on the eye for
uh on the lookout for all kinds of
insane mcu tie-ins whether it's mutants
or any kind of scroll slash secret
invasion i'm happy taking a break from
scrolls for now
since we just got one in one a vision um
and things like the young of interest
like if isaiah bradley is in
this his grandson is elijah bradley who
is uh in the comics patriot
you know one of the young avengers uh
and there's also been some theories that
there might be some tie in with
black widow because originally black
widow was supposed to precede this
and there were some theories that maybe
they would never put falcon winter
soldier before black widow because
there's a character from blackwood who's
supposed to appear in it like elena
belova
or thaddeus ross or red guardian we'll
see
we'll see black widow has been kind of
like radio silent uh
this whole year other than it'll be in
theaters
but yeah i don't know it might be on its
own island
it's so weird like you know now that
we're moving forward into phase four
um once black widow finally comes out
like going backwards in time and just
being like oh we're we're back here in
phase three i guess
um but yeah no black widow has been
oddly silent
um yeah so i don't know we'll see how
that one goes
but i do have another theory as to who
we might see
in uh talking when we're soldier i think
we might actually see red skull
oh the man is himself the man's himself
because
he he's all done he's uh he's done two
times over actually
because uh gamora and then black widow
so both those versions are done
so we could see um red skull appear
again because he's just like hey
i'm back again didn't um ross marquand
mentioned something like
you know they asked him well now that
the soul stone has been acquired
is your you know whatever your
job is are you relinquished from duty
for doing that
and i think he mentioned that like the
writers had talked to him about an idea
of like
red skull returning to earth and looking
down on earth and being like ah yes
there's so much more i can do here uh
but he's like it never ended up showing
up anywhere
red skull would be nuts to see i thought
seeing red skull like an infinity war
was already pretty crazy
i peed myself a lot um in the theater i
was very shocked i was not
expecting that one meaning um but yeah
no it's i honestly think that he could
definitely make an appearance
um i have this weird theory that there's
actually two red skulls out there
because we did have two red skulls
um because we have the gamora red skull
that we're at the gamora down
from a different timeline an alternative
red skull this
this this red skull and if you see i
don't know this is this is a weird
theory trait that i'm on but if you look
back at the footage
in in endgame and infinity war as soon
as the sacrifice is made
a portal shoots up into the sky and oh
the
beam of light yeah and that i think that
that is where
red skull went up both times
through this wormhole and like now he's
in the process of being
transferred to wherever he's going it
could you know it might not even
um follow within the realms of time
maybe he's just going through
time and space and like all right i can
go into any point in in in anything
so i don't know that's just a weird
theory that i love that theory
i think that's exciting uh i i
personally want red skull to show back
up in the mcu but maybe something like
in uh an avengers secret wars movie he
just shows up in battle world
it's like yeah red skull's back you know
we're gonna close out with a new segment
that we're gonna
maybe end each episode with that's gonna
break down each of the cap wannabes of
the series cause it's all about who gets
to carry the legacy who we want on our
left
uh we're gonna call it oh cat my cat
we're gonna ask which potential cap
successor would you say
that's my cap which would you say not my
cat
and i'll put on a cap for this maybe
we'll sell new caps for this
nice now you're undercover in the mcu
let's start with sam wilson that's my
capper not my cat
that's my cap dog you know that's my cat
man that's my cap too
he's great i love it like he said the
comics
are so good like they're just phenomenal
so yeah but what about bucky barnes
bucky bonds i mean like i i really do
like him as captain america but like
i'm more of a sam wilson guy so yeah i'm
gonna say not my cap but like sort of my
cam
yeah i'll say not my cap to bucky barnes
but if he is your cap that's okay it's
just
this version of bucky barnes he just uh
he's an amazing winter soldier
he embodies the spirit of the winter
soldier but not captain america i
wouldn't want to put him
i don't i don't want to saddle him with
that shield it's not the burden i want
him to carry
and it would be kind of hard for him i
feel you know given everything that he's
done in this his
his terrible reputation just to be like
all right i'm
captain america now the face of america
i don't know if that's going to go well
with a lot of people
no um especially you know the stark
foundation i'm sure they're going to be
like
i don't know man
um all right i think we both agree u.s
agent john walker
not my cap not my cap no yeah not
anyone's cat not even his own cap he
knows deep down he doesn't deserve this
he's got major imposter syndrome and he
deserves
um uh how about helmut zemo obviously
not my cap for the terrible things he's
done
yeah but um you know in another universe
if he was a good boy he'd be a very
smart captain america
yeah but no not my cap yeah he i
mentioned him because he might follow
the citizen v
arc where he is trying to be a version
of captain america
with another name but yeah not my cap i
like zemo
what about if uh if carl umbly or if
isaiah bradley is part of this
not my cap or that's my cat i mean
that'd be my cap i mean if it was
like initially like yeah that'd be my
cap i'd be all about it
yeah i want to hear his story absolutely
i would say that's my kid yeah
battle star if lamar hoskins is in this
what do you say not my cat i'm gonna say
not my captain yeah i'm listening all
the way
sam winston i would say he would be a
smaller character in this
uh but i would hope he would be part of
the team that brings down
us agent if he gets to hold the shield
briefly that'd be pretty great okay now
let's talk about
old old man cap old steve rogers he's
still around
he might be getting buried in that first
episode
but that's my cat that's got to be my
cap dawg
always been my camera he'll always be
our cat yeah
yeah he's always in here he'll always be
in here man yeah oh man yeah it's gonna
be so sad if he does go
um but yeah he'll always be my cab and
uh and we will leave it there for now
but we'll we'll check in on these names
every episode uh maybe sharon carter
could join that mix she could beat cat
why not everybody can be cap we're all
cap everyone's gone
you get to be count you get to be
uh but that is it for this preview
episode of inside marvel the one
uh i almost said the one division after
show it's not even in the script it's
our after show for the falcon
and the winner soldier uh mt and i will
be back next friday march 19th uh
in the morning i think we're gonna aim
for 9 a.m pacific time
uh noon uh east coast time for our
reaction to the premier episode of the
falcon winter soldier
and our after show we're going to try to
answer all the questions you had about
the episode
so a reminder to join us live using the
stereo app by downloading stereo at
stereo.com
new rockstars so that you can listen to
all of our shows on stereo and you can
submit your questions and theories
heroes respond in real time and you can
download the app for free on apple and
android
create an avatar and profile so now mt
and i are going to turn to our listeners
on stereo
our patient facial listeners we're going
to take your questions in a bonus q a
segment that will go up on the channel
on sunday in the meantime follow mt
mastertainment on youtube and
twitter and instagram follow me at eavos
follow rockstar subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching and uh we're
gonna leave you with our
favorite moment from the trailer so far
just blank
sweet jesus i mean how old are you
you